Оборонний бюджет Сполучених Штатів,
погоджений цього тижня в Конгресі США,
наробив чимало галасу. Документ обсягом
у 3,5 тисячі сторінок містить ось такий пункт:
введення санкцій щодо компаній, які надають судна
для будівництва певних російських газопроводів,
що експортують паливо. Автори цього документу
вважають, що такі заходи дозволять зберегти
енергетичну безпеку Європи. Раніше
прокоментувати майбутні санкції США
DW попросила Ґергарда Манґотта,
експерта з питань Східної Європи.
- Чинна законодавча база дозволяє
запроваджувати санкції проти учасників проекту
будівництва газопроводу "Північний потік-2":
Royal Dutch Shell, Юніпер, Engie, OMV та інших.
Ідеться також про санкції щодо укладальників труб
на великих глибинах.
Ухвалений документ робить запровадження санкцій США,
по суті, обов'язковим. Санкції накладаються
на компанії, судна яких прокладають труби
на глибині 100 футів нижче рівня моря, тобто
від 30 метрів і глибше. А також на осіб, які сприяють
продажу, оренді та іншим, зокрема таємним,
оборудкам, що надають ці судна для будівництва
російських трубопроводів. Покарання за порушення
санкцій - заборона видачі американських віз
або анулювання вже виданих,
заморожування майна та активів на території США.
Німецькі лобісти зі свого боку вкрай критично
відреагували на плани американського парламенту
запровадити обмеження щодо компаній, які
беруть участь у будівництві "Північного потоку-2".
Так, у Східному комітеті німецької економіки
вважають, що нові штрафні санкції зводять нанівець
зусилля "нормандської четвірки" з досягнення миру на Донбасі.
У заяві комітету також вказується, що всі необхідні
дозволи для прокладання газопроводу в Євросоюзі
отримані, а спроба втручання американської сторони
стала б більше ніж актом недружелюбності, оскільки
це завдало б значної шкоди
трансатлантичним відносинам, вибудуваним
на взаємоповазі. Кінець цитати.
Як вважають експерти, якщо США
запровадять нові санкції, Берлін опиниться
під тиском.
-  Річ у тім, що Берлін перебуває під тиском і інших
фінансових заходів впливу. Ідеться також
про заходи щодо німецького автопрому.
Якби Німеччина спробувала помститися,
покаравши американців за санкції проти "Північного потоку-2",
вона б опинилася в дуже вразливому становищі
у зв'язку з обмежувальними заходами
проти німецького автопрому,
так що позиція уряду Німеччини в цьому питанні
відносно слабка.
На урядовій конференції в Берліні
плани Конгресу прокоментували так:
- Наша позиція щодо екстериторіальних санкцій чітка.
Ми їх відкидаємо. Але спершу необхідно почекати
і подивитися, які саме рішення будуть ухвалені
Конгресом США. На даний момент їх ще немає.
Але ми стежимо за цим процесом.
Водночас, на думку багатьох експертів, нові санкції
не покладуть хрест на "Північному потоці-2".
- Поки що це законопроект. Можливо,
його проголосують до 20 грудня, тобто до того дня,
коли Конгрес має піти на різдвяні канікули.
Але в силу він може вступити в кращому випадку
лише десь у березні. До цього часу зрозуміло, що
всі будівельні роботи в морі будуть уже завершені.
Поки що є рішення лише Палати представників.
Наступного тижня - голосування в Сенаті, яке,
найімовірніше, буде успішним, адже законопроект
спільно розробили збройні комітети обох палат
парламенту США. Після цього - підпис президента Трампа.
Якщо нові санкції все ж наберуть чинності,
вони можуть негативно позначитися
на відносинах між Берліном і Вашингтоном.